[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to paul
giamatti is one of our greatest living
actors and the Rhino from amazing
spider-man 2 and this blue guy who
tormented malcolm in the middle' we're
talking about that one in 2002 a couple
of rising stars we're on the rise rise
frankie muniz being malcolm from malcolm
in the mill and paul giamatti being that
guy I knew was goodbye never bothered to
learn his name until after I saw him in
sideways yet you all don't why so
Universal said these two must be in a
film together the screen demands oh oh
if it Amanda Bynes in there because
she's something for a minute - and since
we got big fat liar and adequately
passable hit the pits my time when it
came out there's a lot of kids who grew
up with this movie and seem to remember
it with fond memories well I'll be the
judge of what you remember fondly it's
time to take a look at this film and see
if it holds up to the okay praises that
have been projected onto it let's see
the film that actually landed Paul
Giamatti the role of John Adams I'm
actually keeping him in to see how many
you guys are looking that up to see if
that's true this is a big fat liar we
open with the typical 2000 song that
once again sounds like an old smoking
woman has something in her throat
I don't know I can't hack it I've got
music sucked back as Frankie Muniz plays
a boy named Jason who gets tripped by
some bullies who's to keep a look like
those fingers have been up them yeah
they've been up them they steal his
skateboard which means he's late to
school and therefore gets locked out how
exactly does this work when we used to
scrub we were punished by being kept
there not by being kept out
he gets the attention of his friend
Kaylie played by Amanda Bynes who makes
a distraction in class while he sneaks
in you look a little flushed I was just
creating your cross drift
why don't you read us your story you
know what let's give someone else a
chance you did do it didn't you like how
you did Thomas hey in church inside
waits another paul giamatti film you
were in ok that joke was much more
underdeveloped I thought it's a work in
progress meanness tells a big lie about
why he was late and dares her to call
his dad to verify you are lying through
your teeth you little demon call my dad
if you want I think I will let me just
abandon the class for what I could
easily do later kids educate yourselves
hello he gives her his number of course
and pretends to be his father back off
Grim Reaper are you done living yet our
education dollars at work as she
apparently falls for a kid mid voice
crack as an adult man you just take your
time handing in that assignment thank
you ok what did those later seasons of
Grey's Anatomy do to you that was stupid
beyond stupid hello
what Oh I'll ask right now is there we
see more butts here a seam up away in a
minute to her credit she does follow up
and calls the parents in to catch him in
his lie he's required to write a
fictional story and head to N or else
he'll go to summer school he gets a
burst of inspiration though I've writes
a story called big fat liar must be a
political thriller
however he crashes into a limo on the
way to drop it off what's going on here
I need a ride what am i running a taxi
service if I did I would have made that
wrong turn into down Abbey season for I
was a weird detour I was I thought
Giamatti plays Marty wolf a Hollywood
producer who's made some stinkers in the
last few years you have made some
stinkers in the last few years yeah well
everyone has a dry spell Ebert died
kicked over abused by
dropping critic names in my movies
though ah all it takes is one hit to get
you back on top yeah so I'm counting on
with this story I'm handing in Oman tieu
tell me more about that even for a
self-centered jerk that's a weird move
that's like showing someone you don't
care by saying tell me more about your
story pie Giamatti actually shares some
tips on how to be a better liar because
you know he's from Hollywood as he drops
him off at the school
now get out I got a movie to produce
sorry I just did two movies with Jim
Carrey he's still rubbing off on me
Munez drops his paper though and she
Ahmadi reads it in the car coming to the
next logical scene Steve Urkel talking
to a chicken as a cop okay I'll bite how
does this happen oh it's a movie said
Giamatti is on I'll let your first big
mistake long double you think about
throughout the rest of the movie is what
the hell was that goddamn Oracle chicken
movie about Giamatti doesn't get on with
this big star is still trying to figure
out the plot to it aren't you I am
Giamatti doesn't get along with this big
star as he keeps calling an Urkel I did
not tell you to stop acting Turk Oh wolf
how many times have I told you not to
call me purple
call me sanic sanic I'm not gonna lie I
kind of love Julie a white in this role
it's brief but it's pretty goddamn funny
I'm getting nothing from the chicken
that's the problem okay you just sits
there with his head off slumped over I
have absolutely no idea what my
motivation is I give more motivation
acting in scooby-doo and guess who 2019
look it up meanwhile it looks like Munez
doesn't get his paper in so he's sent to
summer school taught by a wide-angle
lens with a guy stuck in it
w
[Music]
looks like a 90s commercial before the
product is shown you know the part where
adults don't understand Munez goes to a
movie theater and sees a trailer for the
story he wrote he's so angry he
literally floats out of his seat Frankie
they all flirt I guess this is clever
but all he can think about some
moviegoers feeling Frankie Muniz junk
creep up on her head whoa whoa hey I'm
sorry I'm sorry you just got in the way
of my symbolic gesture what do you mean
have heard that one before he tells us
folks about the idea being stolen but
they don't believe him because of all
his lying in the past he goes to Kaley
who's busy tutoring the bully who took
his skateboard bet you wish you still
had your skateboard ha Shepard let's see
fully developed brain skateboard I think
I'll take the brain but I have your
skateboard that is some of the most
perfectly written dialogue ever it's
perfect I just wanted to point that out
he has Keeley to come with into LA to
give revenge but she has to stay with
her senile grandma
so they send in the bully dressed as her
as they promised to do all it's summer
school homework it's just Kaylee grandma
they do very little to make him seem
like anyone else and it's kind of
amazing invention like 220 230 for you
it takes a lot of work to be that lazy I
salute your creativity Oh bullshit let
me get to LA and come across Turk from
Scrubs as a limo driver hi I'm mr.
Stroup just your kind of young to be the
biggest fur coat distributor of the
Midwest no it's a family business okay I
wonder if this is how I lost the other
every job I ever had but this isn't an
LA movie without limo ceilings opening
up and fisheye lenses of palm trees oh
and did Universal make this wizard that
shit but will they play Ninja Gaiden hi
so they get out of the bus and trying to
find gia Mahdi's office here you know
that extra is trolling uh sir he was
given very strange direction don't we
have enough weird chicken shit in this
movie
[Music]
don't smile at that uma Thurman was
wedding one of those for Batman and
Robin that show up and burn for so many
reasons they locate his office but have
to find a way to sneak in no no no no
okay
bet you didn't know he was on the debate
team they called the secretary from a
different phone and quite cruelly say
she parked her car on a dog I always
give credit to movies that show kids for
the real assholes they are Oh your
grandma also died saving five kittens
from a fire the kittens are also dead
Yuma sneaks into his office and demands
him to call his dad to admit he stole
his homework
he lights the story on fire though and
admits he's never gonna confess to
stealing it it's a dog-eat-dog town we
play by our own rules in the industry we
call this the Carlos Mencia you asked
for it you asked for it Munez has thrown
out of the office but that doesn't stop
him for he steals his Anna Newton I
should I only know her from that Simpson
joke and they look up his schedules they
find a proper room to lay low and give
him some credit they actually do have
props and costumes from actual movies
even if they are just the bad ones oh
that's the suit from the shitty Grinch
oh that's the puppet from the shitty
Jurassic Park
oh that's Clifford's dick I don't know
him all they have fun messing around and
even discover the sodas are free from
the machine
what's with the cokes machine its rage
free now for vengeance incredibly
awkward and hyped up on coke now you'll
blend in as someone from Hollywood
[Applause]
[Music]
so the call Turk to pick them up even
though he finally puts together what's
going on I got some already dialogue for
you but I'm gonna keep it PG I'm gonna
keep it PG so technically that means I
can use the f-word once and by god I'm
gonna exploit that loophole keep finds
out though thereafter Marty wolf who
ruined his career as an actor and not
just because he was in skylines oh that
is reason enough and he wants in on the
revenge they spend the day stalking him
to kick down his everyday routine
including his meeting with a director
played by John Chow birds descending
from the heavens like wing it
messages from above beckoning
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa Confucius say
easy does it Skippy oh you did not just
Confucius me you know Confucius has a
saying about that adapter grab a bunch
of props in costume is to sabotage his
day but by looking how he gets up in the
morning it kinda seems like he'll
sabotage himself at some point it's show
time
mr. funny bones took his training from
Planet of the Apes very seriously the
poor blue dye into his pool and home
alone all his stuff while he swims
well if Shawn young can dress up like
Catwoman to try and force a recast I can
dress up like David Cross to try and be
on Arrested Development actually maybe
that's not such a good idea oh yeah
those five steps you took from the car
totally warranted a slo-mo dissolve
reverse dubstep boy you're gonna have to
cancel the meeting and get one of the
makeup chicks to meet me at the office
he looks like queer eye for this drink
Rover primary colors are always funny
for some reason I'm all over they send
Wolfe to the wrong house though and he
interrupts a kid's birthday party who
confuse him for a clown again embracing
asshole children seek them better when
the adults start attacking the kids
[Music]
the men do against such Restless hate he
escapes though only to find his car has
been tampered with and every button does
the opposite of what he wants
hey Marty I like you your coloring it
works for you you did this
yep Benny can end any time all I have to
do is make one phone call to my dad oh
and also if you ever want to see your
five-year-old son again you'll do as we
say oh yeah we play dark
he hasn't only crashes into a street
fighter' cure do gets pissed off and
runs his car over they told me to pick
up a little blue car they didn't say
anything about a little blue man well
that's my line
I said it and I'm proud you have to
cancel his big meeting and show up to
the premiere of that or cold chicken
movie no the other one
I agree it strange that there's two
ready to end this
it's looking like an Andy Warhol
painting of the Joker
Joaquin Phoenix should take notes Oh kid
do you have no idea who you are dealing
with do you know how many kids I've
buried
I'm not talking about careers I'm
talking dirt and shovels to LA baby the
after-party brings out all sorts of
former child actors to say that the film
they saw was total trash for example
when you did save my belt okay wow that
is bad when screech is dumping on your
film his resume has this on it
the movie is so bad that the studio
president is pulling funding on big fat
liar so they had a trailer before they
even shot a movie Oh Who am I kidding
sometimes the movies not even finished
by the time it's released the president
gives him one more chance as he says he
has a big secret about the film what is
this big presentation you're giving
about the movie I have no idea it sounds
like the final production meeting for
fan 4 stick munis says he can help
though as he feeds an info through an
earpiece
but Wolff decides to go it alone and
wins the crowd over including the
president he of course doesn't call
Munez his dad though and has them
arrested by security who planned to send
them all for Jason Shepard you can get
out of anything dead it's Jason I
haven't been totally honest about what
I've been up to the last couple days oh
that's right it's the third act and this
is still in early 2000s movie mm-hmm
we failed everybody until it didn't work
we really didn't make it gonna spend a
lot of time make you think this was all
for nothing except for one last fight
it's payback time
or not a lot of time god bless you yeah
they have that bullshit in there but it
is quick so here's your pass it looks
like Wolf's assistant is tired of being
kicked around by him and so are all the
people who ever came in contact with him
so they put together a plan to get him
back on the first day of shooting the
film I know you yeah you do Frank
Jackson how would you drive a last year
to be fired me
fabulous I don't the way he perks up
when he sees someone whose life is
ruined
boy the acting career has really be
taken on Bravo Brando
now drive me to where I need to be
person who has my life in his hands the
car seems to break down but Jaleel White
shows up seemingly to give him a ride it
seems like he's such a crazy driver
though that Giamatti drops out of his
car you're underrated and I hope the
best for you wow it is really hard to
say anything bad about him but the
craziness isn't done yet as a helicopter
with a stunt coordinator picks him up
but says the copter is gonna crash so
they have to jump hey how much is it
costing us to essentially lose our jobs
oh well who cares he's come feel so
silly hey wolf he lands on a Western
sale where he comes across Munez who's
in possession of his toy I feel like I
missed a page of script how do we get to
this point give me back my monkey come
and get him he chases him down to get
his monkey I can't really wish I saw
that page and their lives were a bunch
of movie sets because it was really cool
wimpy we did it
oh my god they doing a sequel to Batman
Returns an actual sequel wolf catches up
with him though to get his toy so you
admit you stole my story yeah I stole
your story
I stole Jason Shepards paper and turned
it in a big fat liar I want to just
repeat that cuz I'm sure nobody is
listening I stole it of course it's
recorded and he's exploited for the big
fat liar that he is okay this is an
origin story for a Batman villain right
got you
Muniz jumps off the building into a
giant pillow where his parents saw the
whole thing
look this movie even got made with Turk
as the star yeah I started calling him
Julia White but he's still Turk to me
oh I apologize I forgot you were there
you may go now
Muniz gets the credit he deserves and
Giamatti gets a job as what else a clown
at where else the kids party of the
Street Fighter character oh my god show
me no crap still more dignified than
turbo and that was big fat liar and it
was big fat fun the characters are all
pretty likable and funny it doesn't make
much sense but it establishes it's an
environment where it doesn't really have
to it's like a high budget well-written
Disney Channel movie except there's less
focus on emotion and more on jokes but
the jokes do usually work and there's
just enough emotion as the kid doesn't
want any money for the idea he just
wants his credibility returned that's
such a silly thing in many respects but
it's definitely a kid thing to do too
maybe it's the best way I can describe
it silly
buffer kids but even a few good Labs
thrown in for adults it's nothing great
it's just the right amount of goofy for
me
now I'm honest I wish I could a guy
remember so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
give me back my monkey
hey dub Walker here doing the charity
shout-out and this week we are doing
food bank for New York food bank for New
York has been the city's major hunger
relief organization working to end
hunger throughout the five boroughs for
more than thirty years nearly one in
five New Yorkers relies on food bank for
food and other resources it takes a
strategic multifaceted approach that
provides meals and build capacity in the
media's communities while raising
awareness and engagement among all New
Yorkers through its network of more than
1,000 charities and schools citywide
food bank provides food for more than 63
million free meals for New Yorkers in
need if you look at their site in their
YouTube channel you can not only see in
great detail how they helped but who
they helped too this is also a wonderful
organization to volunteer at if you're
in the area carrying an A rating at
charity watch click on the link and give
to those who never deserve to go to bed
hungry
[Music]
you